Alright, let's do this.
[INAUDIBLE]
new. Oh my goodness. Why does it want all this information, Sam?
>> In order to sign up for a free developer
account, you have to give them a little bit of
information. But giving them your e-mail, so that they can
send you the sign-up information to be able to log in.
>> What if I didn't have a company? Could I just put none?
>> You could put none. But it's asking for some geographical location just to
send you information about cool events that might be coming up in your area.
>> What's the deal in here? Username,
is that different from my email?
>> The username can be the same as your email, but if you already have a
developer edition account or any account under that
email, it'll probably ask you for a new username.
>> Oh. Oh yeah. Whoops, I need a new one.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, so what should I do? Just
like Andy, can I just do like Andy@udacity.awesome? Yup.
>> All right. I may have actually used
this one already, too. Yup. Let's do andy@udacity.sweet. Okay.
>> Awesome.
>> No, sweet.
>>
[LAUGH]
So, the great thing about the developer edition account is, it's
free, it never expires, and it's your own little test environment
to build any sort of app that you might want to
in it. Okay. Says I should receive an email. Let's check.
>> So, click into that.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, so this one isn't actually the login email, but
they send this out automatically when you sign up. It gives
you some cool links to getting started and, you know, learning
about the platform if you're new to it, but the other one
is the actual log-in link.
>> There it is. Okay. Log-in confirmation. I'm not going to
read this. I'm going to click this. Okay. password, right. Alright.